The next random variable that
we will discuss is the
binomial random variable.
It is one that is
already familiar
to us in most respects.
It is associated with the
experiment of taking a coin
and tossing it n times
independently.
And at each toss, there
is a probability, p,
of obtaining heads.
So the experiment is completely
specified in terms
of two parameters--
n, the number of tosses, and p,
the probability of heads at
each one of the tosses.
We can represent this experiment
by the usual
sequential tree diagram.
And the leaves of the tree are
the possible outcomes of the
experiment.
So these are the elements
of the sample space.
And a typical outcome is a
particular sequence of heads
and tails that has length n.
In this diagram here, we took
n to be equal to 3.
We can now define a random
variable associated with this
experiment.
Our random variable that we
denote by capital X is the
number of heads that
are observed.
So for example, if the outcome
happens to be this one--
tails, heads, heads-- we have
2 heads that are observed.
And the numerical value of our
random variable is equal to 2.
In general, this random
variable, a binomial random
variable, can be used to model
any kind of situation in which
we have a fixed number of
independent trials and
identical trials, and each trial
can result in success or
failure, and we have a
probability of success equal
to some given number, p.
The number of successes obtained
in these trials is,
of course, random and
it is modeled by a
binomial random variable.
We can now proceed and calculate
the PMF of this
random variable.
Instead of calculating the whole
PMF, let us look at just
one typical entry of the PMF.
Let's look at this entry, which,
by definition, is the
probability that our random
variable takes the value of 2.
Now, the random variable taking
the numerical value of
2, this is an event that can
happen in three possible ways
that we can identify in
the sample space.
We can have 2 heads followed
by a tail.
We can have heads,
tails, heads.
Or we can have tails,
heads, heads.
The probability of this
outcome is p times p
times (1 minus p).
So it's p squared times
(1 minus p).
And the other two outcomes
also have the same
probability, so the overall
probability is 3 times this.
Which can also be written this
way, 3 is the same as
3-choose-2.
It's the number of ways that you
can choose 2 heads, where
they will be placed
in a sequence of
3 slots or 3 trials.
More generally, we have the
familiar binomial formula.
So this is a formula that
you have already seen.
It's the probability of
obtaining k successes in a
sequence of n independent
trials.
The only thing that is new is
that instead of using the
traditional probability
notation, now
we're using PMF notation.
To get a feel for the binomial
PMF, it's instructive to look
at some plots.
So suppose that we toss the coin
three times and that the
coin tosses are fair, so that
the probability of heads is
equal to 1/2.
Then we see that 1 head or 2
heads are equally likely, and
they are more likely than the
outcome of 0 or 3 heads.
Now, if we change the number of
tosses and toss the coin 10
times, then we see that
the most likely result
is to have 5 heads.
And then as we move away from
5 in either direction, the
probability of that
particular result
becomes smaller and smaller.
Now, if we toss the coin many
times, let's say 100 times,
the coin is still fair, then
we see that the number of
heads that we're going to get is
most likely to be somewhere
in this range between,
let's say, 35 and 65.
These are values of the random
variable that have some
noticeable or high
probabilities.
But anything below 30 or
anything about 70 is extremely
unlikely to occur.
We can generate similar plots
for unfair coins.
So suppose now that our coin is
biased and the probability
of heads is quite low,
equal to 0.2.
In that case, the most likely
result is that we're going to
see 0 heads.
And then, there's smaller and
smaller probability of
obtaining more heads.
On the other hand, if we toss
the coin 10 times, we expect
to see a few heads, not a very
large number, but some number
of heads between, let's
say, 0 and 4.
Finally, if we toss the coin 100
times and we take the coin
to be an extremely unfair one,
what do we expect to see?
If we think of probabilities as
frequencies, we expect to
see heads roughly
10% of the time.
So, given that n is 100, we
expect to see about 10 heads.
But when we say about
10 heads, we do not
mean exactly 10 heads.
About 10 heads, in this
instance, as this plot tells
us, is any number more or less
in the range from 0 to 20.
But anything above 20 is
extremely unlikely.